well there are 13,000 customs items on
the customs unions spreadsheet over
13,000 if we leave the European Union on
my basis of free trade almost all theirs
go so the whole job becomes much much
simpler said the Public Accounts
Committee is assuming that you apply the
current customs regulations that would
be mistake what we want to do is move to
free trade get rid of all these tariffs
and non-tariff barriers to really open
up the United Kingdom and then this is
not necessary the other really striking
thing you've said is that the 350
million pounds for the NHS that was a
commitment made by the leave campaign it
wasn't a commitment made by the
Conservative Party all the government so
why are you urging the government to do
this you're absolutely right but I think
when you make promises the electorate
looks at the promise in broad terms and
doesn't say oh well this is only the
promise of part of the Conservative
Party or of the leave campaign I think
voters reasonably thought it was a
promise that was being made in the event
that we voted to leave and that when
they waited to leave they were voting to
leave but also for 350 million pounds a
week for the NHS once we had left and I
think politicians would be wise to
deliver on implied promises as well as
ones that are nailed down without any
sub clauses and small print looking at
the breakfasts negotiations you said
that the Chancellor needed to double the
amount of money whose pudding by as a
contingency 250 million pounds extra
isn't a great deal of money in the great
scheme of things so why don't you think
he's done that well I mean I agree with
you 250 million pounds in the great
scheme of government expenditure is not
the largest amount it will spend I was
saying further contingency on top of
that which may well not be needed and I
think the government needs to be shown
very clearly to our interlocutors in the
EU that we will be ready on day one
without a deal I think it's very
important from a negotiating standpoint
but also it may happen and if it does
happen we have to be ready and not gets
the position a few months before the
deadline where the EU can face us with
almost anything because the EU knows we
won't be ready why is the Chancellor not
doing that well
he will do it in his budget next week do
you think the EU deliberately stalling
the talks the phase one talks so they
can just ratchet up the amount of money
they get from us
oh yes that's of course mine they're
doing it the EU from its own point of
view is negotiating in a perfectly
reasonable way in a way that things will
get it the most we have to be very clear
that this way of negotiating will in
fact get it the least because if we
leave without a deal that multi-annual
financial framework is insolvent
you two'll attracted by this suggestion
that northern ireland would remain
within the single market and customs
union as a part of the UK with special
status like Hong Kong has with China
Margaret Thatcher said that nan Arland
was as much part of country essentially
in my view nan and as much as part the
country at sunset that it is part of my
country part of my nation it is not like
Hong Kong an administrative region of
our greater whole it is part of the
United Kingdom the conservative and
unionist parties committed to that and
will not break up the United Kingdom for
the convenience of miss Jo Barney
so we have a vote in the Commons this
evening how many Conservative MPs are
going to vote against the government do
you think over the eight days in
committee stage my expectation is that
the government is pretty safe on all the
votes with the exception of some of the
Henry the 8th clauses they that may be
overtaken by the promise of further
legislation to implement the withdrawal
bill which makes those clauses less
necessary there are a number of Labour
MPs who will vote with the government
who have committed to delivering on
brexit not all breaks of tears but
committed to livering on on brexit and
there's a relatively small number of
conservative rebels and it from my point
is quite interesting because I used to
be on the other side of this I used to
be one of the rebels against more Europe
and we were very rarely enough to defeat
the government and I think the same
applies now